This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. You're going to build a wall. It's going to be a real wall. See that ceiling up there? I mean, this is a wall that if you get up there, you're not coming down very easily. True. True. One week into his presidency, Donald Trump signed an executive order to begin building a wall between the U.S. and Mexico. Trump says it will be, quote, an impenetrable, physical, tall, powerful, beautiful southern border wall. But campaign slogans are easy. Reality is harder. That's Joe Richmond from Radio Diaries, and on this episode with the help of Radio Diaries,
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。你要修建一堵墙。这将是一堵真正的墙。看到上面的天花板了吗？我的意思是，这是一堵如果你爬上去，就很难下来的墙。没错。没错。在担任总统的一周后，唐纳德·特朗普签署了一项行政命令，开始在美墨边境修建一堵墙。特朗普表示，这将是一堵，引述他的话说，坚不可摧、实体、高大、有气势、美丽的南部边境墙。但竞选口号很容易。现实却更残酷。这是来自“电台日记”的乔·里士满，在本期节目中，在“电台日记”的帮助下，
we're going to tell a few stories about the physical border on the southern edge of the United States. And what happens when instead of people crossing the border, the border crosses the people. Joe Richmond will take it from here. In 2006, President Bush signed a law to begin building an 18-foot high fence, along a few key parts of the US-Mexico border. The project went by different names, Operation Gatekeeper in California, Operation Safeguard in Arizona, and in Texas they called it Operation Hold The Line.
我们将讲述一些关于美国南部边境实体边界的故事。以及当边界没有让人去跨越，而是边界跨越了人时，会发生什么。乔·里士满将从这里继续讲述。2006年，布什总统签署了一项法律，开始在美墨边境的几个关键地段修建一道18英尺高的栅栏。这个项目有不同的名称，在加利福尼亚州被称为“守门人行动”，在亚利桑那州被称为“防护网行动”，而在得克萨斯州，他们称之为“坚守阵线行动”。
Today that fence looks like a somewhat random dotted line, covers about a third of the entire border. Now the border fence has always been controversial, but it's based on a very human impulse, to have an actual physical barrier that marks the imaginary one on the map. It's a simple idea, and like most things, it turned out to not be so simple. Hello. Hello, is this Pamela Taylor?
如今，这道栅栏看起来像一条有点随意的虚线，覆盖了整个边境的大约三分之一。现在，边境栅栏一直是有争议的，但它的基础是一种非常人类的冲动，即拥有一个实际的物理屏障来标记地图上那个想象中的边界。这是一个简单的想法，像大多数事情一样，结果证明并非那么简单。喂。喂，请问是帕梅拉·泰勒吗？
It is. So, can you tell me where you are right now? I'm in my living room. I'm looking out the window. I see my front yard and beyond that is the fence. It is huge. Iron about 20 feet tall. The fence was put in there by Homeland Security.
是的。那么，你能告诉我你现在在哪里吗？我在我的起居室里。我正看着窗外。我看到我的前院，再过去就是那道栅栏。它太巨大了。大约20英尺高的铁栅栏。这道栅栏是国土安全部安装在那里的。
Pamela Taylor is 86 years old. You may have noticed she has a slight British accent, but she's an American citizen. After World War II, she married an American and they moved to a small brick house outside of Brownsville, Texas. That's the house she's in right now, and she's been there for more than 60 years. Now that house is technically in the US, but for the past six years, it's been on the wrong side of the fence. We're on the Mexican side.
帕梅拉·泰勒今年86岁。你可能已经注意到她有一点英国口音，但她是一名美国公民。二战后，她嫁给了一个美国人，他们搬到了得克萨斯州布朗斯维尔郊区的一栋小砖房里。那就是她现在所在的房子，她在那里住了60多年。现在那栋房子在名义上属于美国，但在过去六年里，它一直在栅栏的错误一边。我们在墨西哥这一侧。
The fence is in front of my home. So let me just go over this. For many people thinking about the border fence, they just assume it's on the border. No, it's not true. The Rio Grande River is the legal border between the U.S. and Mexico. But the border fence doesn't follow all the natural contours at that river. If they followed the river, it would be a winding fence, whereas now it is a straight fence, and therefore they did not need to install that much fence. And in the beginning, we were told this fence was going to go right through my living room.
栅栏在我的家前面。所以让我顺一下这个。对于许多考虑边境栅栏的人来说，他们只是假设它在边境上。不，这不是真的。格兰德河是美墨之间的法定边界。但边境栅栏并没有遵循那条河流所有的自然轮廓。如果他们沿着河流走，那将是一道蜿蜒的栅栏，而现在它是一道笔直的栅栏，因此他们不需要安装那么多栅栏。一开始，我们被告知这道栅栏将直接穿过我的起居室。
Luckily they ended up building it about a mile north. Today Taylor has about a half dozen neighbors in the exact same situation as her. Down the road there's also a farm and a golf course all on the Mexican side of the fence. We've gotten used to it now. We just can't go on and be miserable about it. So how would you describe where you are living? Well, actually, it's a no man's land. And I firmly believe that I shouldn't be paying taxes.
幸运的是，他们最终在北边大约一英里处建造了它。今天，泰勒在和她完全相同的情况的邻居大约有半打。顺着路走下去，还有一个农场和一个高尔夫球场，都在栅栏的墨西哥一侧。我们现在已经习惯了。我们不能一直为此感到痛苦。那么你如何形容你居住的地方呢？嗯，实际上，这是一个无人区。而且我坚信我不应该纳税。
A no man's land between two countries. That's what our next story is about. The United States is not as big today as it was at this time yesterday. President Johnson and President Diaz Ordas of Mexico made it the border today and ended an old dispute. The Rio Grande River has been the border between the U.S US and Mexico, ever since Texas became a state. The problem is, rivers can move, and that's exactly what happened in 1864. Tarental rains caused the river to jump its banks and go south. All of a sudden, the border was in a different place.
两个国家之间的无人区。这就是我们下一个故事的主题。今天的美国没有昨天这个时候那么大了。约翰逊总统和墨西哥总统迪亚斯·奥尔达斯将其定为今天的边界，并结束了一场陈年争端。自从得克萨斯州成为一个州以来，格兰德河一直是美国和墨西哥之间的边界。问题是，河流会移动，而这正是1864年发生的事情。暴雨导致河水冲破堤岸向南流去。突然之间，边界到了一个不同的地方。
What that meant is that Texas had gained a square mile of land. It was called the Chamezal, named for the scrubby desert plant that grew there. The Chamezal was a thorn in the side of US-Mexico relations for a century, and then finally 50 years ago, the US gave the land back to Mexico. But by that time, thousands of people had moved to the Chamezal
这意味着得克萨斯州获得了一平方英里的土地。它被称为查梅萨尔，以那里生长的灌木状沙漠植物命名。查梅萨尔是一个世纪以来美墨关系中的一颗眼中钉，最后在50年前，美国将这片土地交还给了墨西哥。但到那时，成千上万的人已经搬到了查梅萨尔，
and made it their home. And that is where this story begins. My name is Mario Heni Atrillo. I grew up in the Chamisal area during the 50s and 60s. I lived one street away from the river, which was the division between the two countries. The river was just more like a highway that you had to cross to get to where you needed to be.
并把它当成了家。这个故事就是从这里开始的。我叫马里奥·埃尼·阿特里略。我在50年代和60年代在查梅萨尔地区长大。我住的地方离作为两国分界线的河只有一条街。这条河更像是一条你需要穿过才能到达你需要去的地方的高速公路。
There was a baseball team on the Mexican side, and then there was a team on the El Paso side and they would just signol each other through whistles and then they would cross. It was just life, life with a river between us. This is an interview as part of the Chamisal oral history project. So Mr. Inohosa, could I ask you to describe the neighborhood? Yes, they were a lot of tenements and a lot of small, I hate to say, checks, but that's what they were. They didn't have any electricity nor running water.
墨西哥那边有一支棒球队，埃尔帕索那边也有一支球队，他们会通过口哨互相打信号，然后他们就会穿过去。这就是生活，夹在我们之间有一条河的生活。这是一次作为查梅萨尔口述历史项目一部分的采访。那么伊诺霍萨先生，我能请你描述一下这个社区吗？是的，有很多廉租公寓和许多小的，我讨厌这么说，棚屋，但事实就是这样。它们既没有电也没有自来水。
But you build one room and then you build another room and then you build another room, one room after the others, they become, I guess, better off. My name is Victor Guzman Garcia. Garcia Clan goes back to about 386 years in this area. A lot of Mexicans from the interior thought that Chame-Zal, which was basically just a square mile of land, they thought it was the largest California, and that it probably had oil and gold.
但你建了一个房间，然后又建了另一个房间，然后又建了另一个房间，一个房间接着另一个房间，它们变得，我想，情况好一些了。我叫维克托·古兹曼·加西亚。加西亚家族在这个地区可以追溯到大约386年前。许多来自内地的墨西哥人认为查梅萨尔，基本上只是一平方英里的土地，他们认为它是最大的加利福尼亚，并且它可能拥有石油和黄金。
So every time there was an issue between two countries, Mexico would of course bring up the Chamisad. My name is Paul Kramer, and I'm an historian, advanced about university, researching the history of the Chamisad. In Mexico, the Chamisad represented illegally occupied territory but in the United States very few Americans had even heard of it and then in the 1960s
所以每当两国之间出现问题时，墨西哥当然会提起查梅萨尔。我叫保罗·克雷默，我是高级大学的历史学家，正在研究查梅萨尔的历史。在墨西哥，查梅萨尔代表着被非法占领的领土，但在美国，很少有美国人听说过它，然后在20世纪60年代，
that all changed in a really unexpected way. And this is NBC News presenting today a new special crisis in Cuba. This government has promised as maintained the closest surveillance of the Soviet military buildup on the island of Cuba within the past. With Cuban missile crisis, and specifically the fact that Mexico does not cut off its ties to Castro, the Kennedy administration becomes very concerned that Mexico could be vulnerable in the Cold War. Suddenly there's a real willingness to remedy the Chamezal dispute, to use it as a kind of bargaining chip.
这一切都以一种真正意想不到的方式改变了。这里是NBC新闻，为您呈献今天关于古巴的新特别危机。本政府已经承诺并保持了对古巴岛上苏联军事建设最密切的监视。随着古巴导弹危机，特别是墨西哥没有切断与卡斯特罗的关系这一事实，肯尼迪政府变得非常担心墨西哥在冷战中可能会变得脆弱。突然之间，人们有了真正愿意弥补查梅萨尔争端、将其用作一种讨价还价筹码的意愿。
And so the big question is, the residents of this tiny patch of land, what's going to happen to them? This is a letter from the International Boundary and Water Commission to Mr. Luis Rivera. Dear sir, we advise that the appraisal of your property would be undertaken as soon as practical preparatory to acquisition by the federal government. It's authorized by the government. As kids or kids, we were eavesdropping
所以最大的问题是，这块极小土地上的居民，他们会怎么样？这是一封来自国际边界和水利委员会给路易斯·里维拉先生的信。尊敬的先生，我们通知您，您的房产评估将尽早进行，为联邦政府收购做准备。这是得到政府授权的。作为孩子，我们当时在偷听，
and we heard there was going to be removal. We remember our fathers dumping around the kitchen, saying, but let's get no up wet and know they can't. We were Mexican by heritage, but we understood that we were American by nationality. People were given a choice of going back to Mexico, and only one man that we know of actually accepted to go back. Everybody else said, no, but we all had to be out by
我们听到将要进行搬迁。我们记得我们的父亲们在厨房里走来走去，说：“绝不，他们不能。”我们在血统上是墨西哥人，但我们明白我们在国籍上是美国人。人们被给予了回墨西哥的选择，据我们所知，只有一个人真正接受了回去。其他人则说，不，但我们必须在
October 1964. This is an interview with W.E. Wood, former government real estate appraiser during the Chame-Sah settlement. How did most of the people feel about leaving their homes? It was mixed. There's one case that I can recall This lady had a very nice home better than the rest of them in the neighborhood And she was not gonna let us in and she couldn't speak English Do you speak Spanish? Yes enough to get by and She told me that she was not going to give her house to those goddamn Mexicans in Mexico.
1964年10月之前全部搬出去。这是对查梅萨尔定居期间的前政府房地产估价师W.E.伍德的采访。大多数人对离开家园有什么感觉？心情很复杂。我能回忆起这样一个案子：这位女士有一个非常漂亮的房子，比邻居的其他房子都要好，她不让我们进去，而且她不会说英语。你会说西班牙语吗？是的，应付得过去。她告诉我，她不会把自己的房子给墨西哥那些该死的墨西哥人。
And that they can go to hell. And I'm going to keep my house. And I will get my guns out. And I will fight. And the day when it came to move, the United States marshals picked her up bodily and put her in a car and put her furniture and storage. My name is Angie Nunez.
并且他们可以见鬼去吧。我要守住我的房子。我要拿出我的枪。我要战斗。到了搬迁的那一天，美国法警把她整个人抱起来放进一辆车里，并把她的家具存入仓库。我叫安吉·努涅斯。
It was a very big disappointment because they did not pay for the house. They paid us for the land. My father had just built four extra rooms in our house. We had central heating. He even had the the bricks made special Adolvi with the hay because the house was going to be that much thicker, that much warmer, that much whatever. And we had to leave all that. One by one the family started moving out.
这是一个非常大的失望，因为他们没有为房子付钱。他们为土地付了钱。我父亲刚刚在我们的房子里多建了四个房间。我们有中央暖气。他甚至让人用干草特别制作了土坯砖，因为房子会更厚、更暖和，无论如何都会更好。而我们不得不离开这一切。家庭开始一个接一个地搬走。
And what was left behind were empty shells of homes and the windows were all boarded up and then yellow ribbon was placed on them so that we couldn't even go into the backyards. So it looked like a crime scene with this yellow tape all over until the only family left was ours. Hours historically was the last one. And I remember my dad said, don't look back. You are forbidden from looking back. And enthusiastic welcome at the U.S. Mexican border for President Johnson and Gustavo Diaz
留下来的是空荡荡的房屋外壳，窗户都被木板封上了，然后上面系上了黄丝带，以至于我们连后院都进不去。所以它看起来像一个犯罪现场，到处都是黄色的胶带，直到剩下的唯一一家人是我们家。从历史记录来看，我们是最后一户。我记得我爸爸说，不要回头。禁止回头看。约翰逊总统和古斯塔沃·迪亚斯·
Oda, arriving together to settle a century-old border dispute. I remember thousands and thousands of people on top of the bridge and I could see Johnson, I could see him sitting at the table and T.S. or Das. Mr. President of the United States of America, distinguished Mr. Johnson. Pretty much the whole of the White House with congressmen and senators and everybody was here. I mean this was a big thing. An unpredictable river has been converted into a controlled source of water for Mexicans and Americans alike. By December 1968, Mexico and the United States jointly sponsor the digging of a cement line channel that will make the river go where the authorities wanted to go in terms of maintaining
奥尔达斯在美墨边境受到热烈欢迎，两人一同抵达以解决一个长达一个世纪的边界争端。我记得桥上有成千上万的人，我能看到约翰逊，我能看到他坐在桌旁和T.S.奥尔达斯在一起。美利坚合众国总统，尊敬的约翰逊先生。几乎整个白宫的国会议员、参议员和其他所有人都来了。我的意思是这是一件大事。一条无法预测的河流已被改造成可供墨西哥人和美国人共同使用的受控水源。到1968年12月，墨西哥和美国共同出资开凿了一条水泥砌衬的河道，将使河流按照当局希望的方向流淌，以维护
the boundary that they want. After speeches, the two men walked over to press the buttons that would detonate a retaining wall about a mile away and send the water down its new channel. At the appointed time, the two presidents approached this black box that's been set up on the bridge, which has these two red buttons, and they're supposed to hit the buttons and detonate these explosives to release the mighty Rio Grande into its new channel. In fact, there's just a puff of smoke, nothing happens. And so very quickly, technicians bulldoze the dam
他们想要的边界。致辞结束后，两人走向前去按下按钮，引爆了一英里外的挡土墙，让水流顺着新河道流下。在指定的时间，两位总统走近这座架设在桥上的黑色盒子，上面有两个红色的按钮，他们应该按下按钮并引爆这些炸药，将汹涌的格兰德河释放到它的新河道中。事实上，只冒起了一缕烟，什么也没发生。所以技术人员很快用推土机推倒了水坝，
and release the river completing the ceremony. It's taken a hundred years, but it's finally done. Next goal has its piece of scruff land back, though perhaps it hasn't decided what to do with it. And the river is once again the International Boundary. It costs $40 million, but it's very tidy this way. Jack Berkins NBC News, Nelfazzo. Well, I'll show you. The river is now encased and cement. That poor thing. encased and cement. That poor thing hits about five feet across. It looks like a muddy creek where we used to go. It was wide. Sometimes it had quite a bit of
释放了河流，完成了仪式。花了一百年，但终于完成了。下一个目标拿回了它那片荒地，尽管也许它还没决定拿它怎么办。这条河再次成为国际边界。它耗资4000万美元，但这样很整洁。杰克·伯金斯，NBC新闻，埃尔帕索。好吧，我给你看。这条河现在被包裹在水泥里。那可怜的东西。包裹在水泥里。那可怜的东西大约有五英尺宽。它看起来像我们以前去的那个泥泞的小溪。它以前很宽。有时它有很多
water and that would ripple across. There's only so much control a man can do on a river. Sooner or later, I personally think that river is going to do what Mother Nature has taught it to do, to move. Well, I woke up this morning, to the door I did go. I found that I was living in old Mexico. I got the chummy's all blue. Tips and blue as I can be, because somebody came and took my house away from me.
水，会在水面上泛起涟漪。人类对一条河流的控制是有限度的。迟早，我个人认为这条河会做大自然教给它的事情，那就是流动。好吧，今天早上我醒来，走到门前。我发现自己生活在老墨西哥。我得了查梅萨尔忧郁症。能有多蓝就有多蓝，因为有人来把我的房子从我身边夺走了。
Well, I was born in American El Paso, and now I'm a citizen of all Mexico. I got the Chameisole. The song you're hearing right now is called The Chameisole Blues, written and recorded by Bob Burns and the Teak Woods in 1963. A year before, the Chameisole was handed back to Mexico. This story was produced by radio diaries that's Joe Richmond, Nelly Gillis, Sarah Kate Kramer, Ben Shapiro, and Deborah George, with help from historian Paul Kramer. I love you.
好吧，我出生在美国的埃尔帕索，现在我是老墨西哥的公民。我得了查梅萨尔忧郁症。你现在听到的这首歌叫《查梅萨尔忧郁症》，由鲍勃·伯恩斯和柚木树林乐队于1963年创作并录制。在查梅萨尔被交还给墨西哥的前一年。这个故事由“电台日记”制作，成员包括乔·里士满、内莉·吉利斯、莎拉·凯特·克雷默、本·夏皮罗和黛博拉·乔治，并得到了历史学家保罗·克雷默的帮助。我爱你。
Radio Diaries is one of the founding members of Radio Topia and one of the true gems of public radio. I implore you to subscribe to their podcast. It's really for your own good. They produce many historical documentaries, but they specialize in giving recorders to ordinary people with extraordinary stories and turning their audio diaries into unforgettable radio. They basically won every award in journalism, and when we started Reotopia, I was so honored that they wanted to work with us. So, Radio Diaries is not part of your podcast diet. You are missing out.
“电台日记”是“电台乌托邦”的创始成员之一，也是公共广播真正的瑰宝之一。我恳求你订阅他们的播客。这真的是为了你好。他们制作了许多历史纪录片，但他们的专长是将录音设备交给了拥有非凡故事的普通人，并将他们的音频日记变成令人难忘的广播。他们基本上赢得了新闻界的所有奖项，当我们创办“电台乌托邦”时，我感到非常荣幸，他们想和我们一起工作。所以，如果“电台日记”不在你的播客日常收听列表中。你可就错过啦。
Find them at radiodiaries.org or at radiotopia.fm. At the tail end of 2017, our own Avery Truffman took a trip to the border herself to look at the architecture of the border wall and the new border wall prototypes. We'll talk to her about what she found right after this. Trump took office in March of 2017. US Customs and Border Protection put out a request for proposals asking private companies for designs of a wall that would divide Mexico and the United States. There were two different requests for proposals or RFPs. One RIP was a wall design made of concrete.
请在radiodiaries.org或radiotopia.fm上找到他们。在2017年的末尾，我们自己的艾弗里·特鲁夫曼亲自去了一趟边境，查看边境墙的建筑结构以及新的边境墙原型。我们将在广告之后跟她聊聊她发现了什么。特朗普于2017年3月上任。美国海关与边境保护局发布了一份提案征集书，向私营公司征集旨在分隔墨西哥和美国的墙的设计方案。有两个不同的提案征集书或称RFP。一个RFP是由混凝土制成的墙体设计。
The other was for a design made of quote unquote, other materials. They were to be between 18 and 30 feet tall. From the submissions they received customs and border protection selected eight and turned them into prototypes. Last October, our own Avery Trouffman went down to see what they looked like. We're not live, right? Nobody's live here, okay? I found myself in a crowd of reporters from Reuters and the Guardian and Univision and Fox and we had all been given hardhats and neon yellow vests and we all piled into an air-conditioned van when we were brought out to a
另一个是采用“其他材料”制成的设计。它们的高度必须在18到30英尺之间。从他们收到的方案中，海关与边境保护局挑选了八个并将其制成了原型。去年十月，我们自己的艾弗里·特鲁夫曼去实地查看了它们的样子。我们没在直播吧？这里没人直播吧，好吧？我发现自己置身于来自路透社、卫报、环球电视台和福克斯的记者群中，我们都分到了安全帽和荧光黄色背心，然后我们一起挤进一辆有空调的面包车，被带到了一个
construction site. Camera men unpacked and hoisted their video cameras like great mechanical carcasses, anchors applied fresh makeup and did warm-ups and then we swarmed around Roy Vrial, all of us jostling to get our microphones in his face. First name is Roy, R-O-Y, last name Vrial. V-I-L-L-A-R-E-A-L. Vrial was the acting Chief Patrol agent for the U.S. Border Patrol and the San Diego sector. He was showing us these eight prototypes for a new border wall between the United States and Mexico. The eight prototypes are near completion.
建筑工地。摄像师们 unpack 并像巨大的机械尸体一样举起他们的摄像机，主播们补了妆并做了热身，然后我们蜂拥围住罗伊·比利亚雷亚尔，所有人都在争挤着把麦克风凑到他脸前。名字叫罗伊，R-O-Y，姓氏比利亚雷亚尔。V-I-L-L-A-R-E-A-L。比利亚雷亚尔是美国边境巡逻队圣迭戈分局的代理首席巡逻特工。他正在向我们展示美国和墨西哥之间新边境墙的这八个原型。这八个原型已接近完工。
Seven of the eight have been completed, and the eighth one should be completed by the end of the week. These eight sample rectangles of border wall are massive, each is 30 feet tall. It's striking in person. If they were actually formed into one continuous wall, they'd block off the mountains in the distance. By now, you've probably seen pictures of these prototypes.
八个中已经完成了七个，第八个应该在本周结束前完成。这八个边境墙的矩形样本非常庞大，每个都有30英尺高。亲眼所见非常震撼。如果它们真的被组合成一堵连续的墙，它们会挡住远处的山脉。到目前为止，你可能已经看过这些原型的图片了。
For our made of concrete, for our made of other materials, one is bright blue, one has molding on the side to make the concrete look like cobblestone, half of them have rounded tops to make it harder to grip. And the determination of the ultimate design is based on the testing and evaluation. We have three specific requirements, which are looking at the subterranean,
其中四个由混凝土制成，四个由其他材料制成，一个是亮蓝色的，一个侧面有模具使混凝土看起来像鹅卵石，其中一半顶部呈圆弧形以使其更难抓握。最终设计的确定是基于测试和评估。我们有三个具体要求，即考察地下的部分，
the ability to dig underneath the prototypes, the penetrability, the aspect of being able to breach or in some way degrade the prototype and scalability. The setup of the eight different prototypes certainly looked like a design competition. And so I asked Vierrial, will there be a winner here? Will there be a winner in the Miss? Well, ultimately the winner is the US government.
在原型下方挖掘的能力，穿透性，能够突破或以某种方式破坏原型的方面，以及可扩展性。这八个不同原型的设置看起来确实像是一场设计竞赛。所以我问比利亚雷亚尔，这里会有一个赢家吗？小姐评选中会有一个赢家吗？嗯，最终的赢家是美国政府。
It is going to be us in that this is going to enhance our border security. Nicely played. Conceptually, what we may have is we could have a singular design that is going to be utilized in some segment along the border, or we may have a combination of the designs paired together and then applied to different areas along the border. It's not exactly clear what will happen with the prototypes. Customs and border protection never specified if they were intended for the entire border or parts of the border, or to fortify existing walls. Because, of course, the part that Trump didn't mention in his
将是我们，因为这将增强我们的边境安全。回答得真妙。从概念上讲，我们可能拥有的是一个将用于边境某个部分的单一设计，或者我们可能拥有组合在一起然后应用于边境不同区域的设计组合。目前还不完全清楚原型会怎么样。海关与边境保护局从未明确说明它们是针对整个边境、边境的部分地区，还是用于加固现有的墙。因为，当然，特朗普在竞选中没有提到的一部分是，美墨边境的三分之一以上已经由某种墙壁或屏障覆盖了。
campaign is that over one-third of the U.S.-Mexico border is already covered by a wall or a barrier of some kind. So now we are here in this administration which ran on the platform that said, I'm going to build a wall and everybody claps and says, yeah, finally, someone's come to build a wall. There's already 650 miles of wall in place. This is Ronald Raell, Professor of Architecture at UC Berkeley, an author of the book, Borderwall as Architecture. In his book, he writes about the long history of the border wall. It has a long life, and it's been around for some time.
所以现在我们处于这个政府之下，其竞选纲领说，我要修建一堵墙，每个人都拍手说，太好了，终于有人来修建一堵墙了。现场已经有650英里的墙了。这是加州大学伯克利分校建筑学教授、\\《边境墙作为建筑\\》一书的作者罗纳德·拉埃尔。在他的书中，他写到了边境墙的悠久历史。它有着漫长的生命，而且已经存在一段时间了。
It's evolved from stone carons. These are just stones placed along the border to say where the border was, because it's just a frontier. Originally, where else is, no one knew where that borderline actually was. An engineer's from both Mexico and the United States went to this kind of no man's land frontier zone after 1848, just to figure out where to place these demarcation stones. Piles of stones were put up in later monuments. Fenses were constructed.
它从石堆演变而来。这些只是沿着边境放置的石头，用来标明边境在哪里，因为它只是一片前沿。最初，在其他地方，没有人知道那条边界线到底在哪里。1848年后，来自墨西哥和美国的工程师来到这种无人区的边界地带，只是为了弄清楚在哪里放置这些分界石。后来竖起了堆积的石头作为纪念碑。人们建造了栅栏。
Mostly, the fences were to keep cattle out because they were ranches on both sides. But eventually, some of those fences became more aggressive, especially between cities, particularly between Senni, Siedro and Tijuana. In 1990, the Army Corps of Engineers came to that Tijuana border. They brought over 40,000 carbon steel corrugated planks, each plank 12 feet long and a quarter inch thick. These had been made for the Vietnam War as portable landing mats for helicopters. And these helicopter landing mats were turned
主要是，这些栅栏是为了把牛挡在外面，因为两边都有牧场。但最终，其中一些栅栏变得更具攻击性，特别是在城市之间，尤其是圣伊西和蒂华纳之间。1990年，陆军工程兵团来到了蒂华纳边境。他们运来了40,000多块碳钢波纹板，每块板长12英尺，厚四分之一英寸。这些是为了越南战争制造的直升机便携式着陆垫。这些直升机着陆垫被
up on their sides into the first official border wall. More and more landing mats were added, and today there are over 60 miles of this landing mat wall. And then in other parts of the border, other kinds of walls and fences were built, of different materials, all varying based on the topography. There's pedestrian fences that allow for visibility on both sides, vehicular fences that are meant for cars not to cross. In his book, Real list, over a dozen types of border wall. One that's very expensive is called the floating fence, and this is here in the Algo Donets
竖立在侧面，变成了第一座官方边境墙。越来越多的着陆垫被添加进来，如今这种着陆垫墙已有60多英里长。然后在边境的其他部分，建造了其他种类的墙壁和栅栏，使用不同的材料，全部根据地形而有所不同。有允许两侧都能看得到的行人栅栏，也有旨在防止汽车穿过的车辆栅栏。在他的书中，拉埃尔列出了十几种类型的边境墙。其中一种非常昂贵的是浮动栅栏，它位于加利福尼亚州的阿尔戈多内斯
dunes in California. The floating fence snakes over huge mountainous dunes and has these mechanical buttresses that keep it from sinking into the sand. So it's designed to be lifted and placed back on the dunes. Otherwise, if you just let it go, it just sinks into the dunes. It's amazing. The border wall is already a building project with significant weight behind it. It's unfettered by laws that regular building projects have to abide by. And that's particularly because of the Secure Fence Act, which passed in 2006 back when George W. Bush was president.
沙丘中。浮动栅栏蜿蜒穿过巨大的多山沙丘，并有这些机械支柱以防止其沉入沙子中。所以它被设计成可以被吊起并重新放置在沙丘上。否则，如果你不管它，它就会沉入沙丘中。这太惊人了。边境墙已经是一个具有巨大分量的建筑项目。它不受常规建筑项目必须遵守的法律的束缚。这主要是因为2006年小布什担任总统期间通过的《安全栅栏法案》。
The Secure Fence Act of 2006 was created so that it could you serve any other law that existed in the United States. So any environmental protection laws, this is more important. Any Native American heritage acts, this is more important. Any wildlife act, the Skier Fence act is more important than any of those.
2006年的《安全栅栏法案》的制定是为了它可以凌驾于美国存在的任何其他法律之上。因此，任何环境保护法，这个更重要。任何美洲原住民遗产法案，这个更重要。任何野生动物法案，安全栅栏法案都比其中任何一个更重要。
And so the wall can be constructed un-inhibited. Which brings us back to those new prototypes that are being considered. And the press junket I went to back in October. The border is very dynamic. It's fluid, it's dynamic. There's crime of some form happening every day here. The prototypes will help influence the future development of our border infrastructure system.
所以这堵墙可以不受阻碍地建造。这就把我们带回了那些正在考虑中的新原型。以及我十月份参加的记者团。边境是非常动态的。它是流动的，它是动态的。每天这里都有某种形式的犯罪发生。这些原型将有助于影响我们边境基础设施系统的未来发展。
When their request for proposals went out, architects were like, what do we do? A number of architecture firms submitted some designs for border walls and other architects submitted blank sheets of paper to waste judges' time. But ultimately, customs and border protection didn't choose any architects at all. These prototypes, like the vast, vast majority of the built environment, bridges, tunnels, towers, houses, airports, luxury apartments, and prisons were mostly made by general contractors. These giant construction firms are very practical.
当他们的提案征集书发出时，建筑师们的反应是，我们该怎么办？一些建筑事务所提交了一些边境墙的设计，而其他建筑师则提交了白纸来浪费法官的时间。但最终，海关与边境保护局根本没有选择任何建筑师。这些原型，就像绝大多数建筑环境一样，桥梁、隧道、塔楼、房屋、机场、豪华公寓和监狱，主要都是由总承包商建造的。这些巨大的建筑公司非常务实。
They safely erect huge structures on time and on budget. Their goal is to appease the client, which in this case is the US government. The eight prototypes were manufactured by six different companies. Would you mind walking us through who these companies are? I'm going to defer that to Mr. DeSale because I don't know them. Ralph DeSale is the spokesperson for Border Patrol and he wasn't quite familiar with the construction companies either. The best he could do was read them off a list.
它们安全地按时、在预算内建造巨大的结构。他们的目标是取悦客户，在这个案例中就是美国政府。这八个原型由六家不同的公司制造。你介意带我们了解一下这些公司是谁吗？我将把这个推迟给德萨尔先生，因为我不知道它们。拉尔夫·德萨尔是边境巡逻队的发言人，他也不是很熟悉这些建筑公司。他能做的最好的就是把它们从名单上读出来。
ELTA North-A-Hess, Cadel, Cadlle, Sterling, KWR, Fisher, Sand. I mean, I'm telling you that. To be fair at the time, I didn't know these companies either. I had never heard of them before, but I've likely been in one of their structures somewhere in one of their tunnels or airports or office buildings. The companies that made these walls are WG8s and Sons from Mississippi, Elta, North America, an Israeli company based in Maryland,
ELTA北美、卡德尔、卡德尔、斯特林、KWR、费舍尔、桑德。我的意思是，我告诉你这个。公平地说，当时我也不知道这些公司。我以前从未听说过它们，但我很可能在他们的某个结构中待过，在他们的某个隧道、机场或办公大楼里。建造这些墙的公司是来自密西西比州的WG8s and Sons，来自马里兰州的以色列公司ELTA北美，
Cadillac Construction in Alabama, Texas Sterling Construction out of Houston, KWR Construction from Arizona, and Fisher Sand and Gravel from Arizona. Now, because of the wall prototypes, people know these companies, and they're talking about their relationships to them. Weeks after I returned from the border, I went to an Oakland City Council meeting, where they were considering passing an ordinance to forbid contracting with any of the companies bidding on the border wall. for supporting our resolution on the border wall to make sure that none of our tax dollars are spent
阿拉巴马州的卡迪拉克建筑公司，休斯顿的得克萨斯斯特林建筑公司，来自亚利桑那州的KWR建筑公司，以及来自亚利桑那州的费舍尔砂石公司。现在，因为这些墙的原型，人们认识了这些公司，并且在谈论他们与这些公司的关系。在我从边境回来几周后，我去了奥克兰市议会会议，他们正在考虑通过一项条例，禁止与任何竞标边境墙的公司签订合同。感谢你们支持我们关于边境墙的决议，以确保我们的税款没有被花费
being invested with any contract or any business that is building this divisive wall that will do nothing to make us safer. Similar measures have also been proposed in other municipalities around the country, including New York City and LA, and they've been floated on the state level in Arizona, California, Illinois, New York,
并投资于任何建设这个分裂之墙的合同或企业，而这堵墙对让我们更安全毫无益处。全国其他城市也提出了类似的措施，包括纽约市和洛杉矶，并且已经在亚利桑那州、加利福尼亚州、伊利诺伊州、纽约州、
Rhode Island, and Wisconsin. This is a prohibition on the state level in Arizona, California, Illinois, New York, Rhode Island, and Wisconsin. This is a prohibition on the city of Oakland doing business with contractors who build the Trump border wall. And the city of Oakland should have absolutely nothing whatsoever to do with it. But there are also critics of these kinds of ordinances. Like Sheree Smith, a representative from Associated General Contractors, or AGC, who stood up at that Oakland City Council meeting and testified on behalf of the Contractors Freedom of Choice.
罗德岛州和威斯康星州在州级层面被提出。这是在亚利桑那州、加利福尼亚州、伊利诺伊州、纽约州、罗德岛州和威斯康星州禁止奥克兰市与建造特朗普边境墙的承包商做生意的禁令。奥克兰市绝对不应该与它有任何关系。但也有人批评这类条例。比如来自全国总承包商协会（简称AGC）的代表谢里·史密斯，她在奥克兰市议会会议上起立，代表承包商的选择自由作证。
AGC opposes any policy or regulation that prohibits a contractor from bidding a construction project because contractors should be able to choose which projects they wish to bid on without fear of reprisal or discrimination. But the ordinance passed. And now companies entering contracts with the City of Oakland, say to build a tunnel or a condo complex, will be required to declare that they are not a part of border wall construction and do not plan to be. And this goes beyond those companies already involved in the prototypes, because new border
AGC反对任何禁止承包商竞标建筑项目的政策或法规，因为承包商应该能够选择他们希望竞标的项目，而不必担心遭到报复或歧视。但该条例通过了。现在，与奥克兰市签订合同的公司，比如建造隧道或公寓综合体，将被要求声明他们不参与边境墙建设，并且不打算参与。这超越了那些已经参与原型的公司，因为新的边境
construction is happening separately from those eight prototypes on the San Diego, Tijuana border. When I've talked to customs and border protection people, their thinking is that, you know, he's the president. This is what he wants. So we're going to, we're going to follow his orders. So they're going through the motions. They're building these prototypes.
建设与圣迭戈-蒂华纳边境的那八个原型是分开进行的。当我与海关与边境保护局的人交谈时，他们的想法是，你知道，他是总统。这是他想要的。所以我们要，我们要听从他的命令。所以他们正在走过场。他们在建造这些原型。
But when it comes down to it, that's not gonna work. That's Melissa Del Bosque, a reporter from the Texas Observer. And according to an article she published last year, there are already plans and motion for the first new section of the border wall, which will run through a wildlife refuge in South Texas. It will be built by Michael Baker International, a construction firm who was not involved
但归根结底，那是行不通的。这是《得克萨斯观察家报》的记者梅丽莎·德尔·博斯克。根据她去年发表的一篇文章，边境墙第一个新路段的计划已经在进行中，该路段将穿越南得克萨斯州的一个野生动物保护区。它将由迈克尔·贝克国际公司建造，这是一家根本没有参与原型的建筑公司。
in the prototypes at all. The proposed design will be a levy wall, which is not among the designs and the prototypes. In terms of the prototypes, what should we make of them? I don't know, I think they're going to sit there like stone hinge probably. You just view them as a symbol? Yeah, yeah, totally. I don't think they mean much other than fulfilling his campaign promise. So whether or not these particular prototypes on display will ever actually be built,
拟议的设计将是一堵防洪堤墙，不在原型设计之中。就原型而言，我们该如何看待它们？我不知道，我想它们可能会像巨石阵一样坐在那里。你只是把它们看作是一个象征？是的，是的，完全是。我认为除了兑现他的竞选承诺之外，它们没有多大意义。所以无论展出的这些特定原型是否真的会被建造，
there will be more walls. I imagine what will happen is what has been happening for decades, and it's not special to the Trump administration at all, which is that some walls are gonna be constructed, because this has been happening through many presidencies, Republican and Democrat alike. Professor Raul Rael again. And so I imagine that's what's gonna happen. There's gonna be some walls built.
还会有更多的墙。我想将要发生的事情将是几十年来一直在发生的事情，这根本不是特朗普政府所特有的，那就是将建造一些墙，因为这已经通过许多总统发生过了，无论是共和党人还是民主党人。再次是劳尔·拉埃尔教授。所以我猜这就是将要发生的事情。将会建造一些墙。
Rael has been studying the various border walls for years, and he's come to believe they're ineffective and inhumane. So, when he first saw the pictures of Trump's prototypes, he thought of the famous saying, show me a 20-foot wall and I'll show you a 21-foot ladder. And so Rayal got to work on a simple act of protest using his skills as an architect. Based on the images of the wall prototypes, he drew up some designs for ladders. 99% of visible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman and Radio Diaries. Our composer is Sean Riel, senior editor Delaney Hall, digital director Kurt Colstead, Senior Producer, Katie Mingle.
拉埃尔多年来一直在研究各种边境墙，他开始相信它们是无效且不人道的。所以，当他第一次看到特朗普原型的图片时，他想到了那句名言：“给我看一堵20英尺高的墙，我会给你看一把21英尺高的梯子。”于是拉埃尔开始利用他作为建筑师的技能采取简单的抗议行动。根据墙体原型的图像，他画了一些梯子的设计图。“99%隐形”本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和“电台日记”制作。我们的作曲家是肖恩·里埃尔，高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔，数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特德，高级制作人凯蒂·明格。
The rest of the team is Emmith Fitzgerald, Shree Fusef, Taren Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Dexter Walcott, Ashton Ham, Patrick McAndreux, James Hurd, Peggy Deamer, and the rest of the Architecture Lobby, a group of concerned architects doing work around the border wall. Find them at architecture-lobby.org. We are a project of 91.7K, a.l.w. in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. We're one of the founders of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows
团队的其他成员是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、什里·菲塞夫、泰伦·马扎以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。本周特别感谢德克斯特·沃尔科特、阿什顿·汉姆、帕特里克·麦克安德鲁、詹姆斯·赫尔德、佩吉·迪默以及建筑游说团体的其他人，这是一群关注边境墙工作的关心建筑的建筑师。请在architecture-lobby.org上找到他们。我们是旧金山91.7KALW的项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的“电台路”。我们是PRX旗下“电台乌托邦”的创始人之一，这是一个汇集了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的集体。
in all of podcasting. We are supported by our listeners, so keep sending me pictures of your freshly applied sticker badges. They make me very happy. You can find 99% of visible and joint discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But all people of every nationality are free to hang
我们得到听众的支持，所以请继续给我发送你们新贴上的徽章贴纸的照片。它们让我非常高兴。你可以在Facebook上找到“99%隐形”并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars）或@节目（@99PIOrg），或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也行。但所有国籍的人都可以在我们的网站99pi.org上自由闲逛。电台乌托邦。
out at our place at 9i9pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。